laughing police so Sean asked me if I
would be willing to share with you guys
so here I am
my name is Bethany our skin I work for
people's post and I know our guests guys
this one's but if anyone who didn't get
to set up the sandbox I have here so you
all here actually likes their monitoring
or is happy with their
how are you
okay you know needles into users no okay
cool so the reason I'm here today is
because I actually like our monitoring
setup has it always been this way
so my story is that in 2001 I joined
paperless post as the second ever member
of our team we're really small teams we
have a lot of challenges but in which
was succeed our monitoring
infrastructure so what we had was a
monolithic navigator server with new
version control new configuration
management and every time we needed to
add to post services checks etc we were
just manually editing the files and
restarting scenario server and even
though I have had years of experience
configuring the Navi Araz think that
they would Frank configuration command
sleep I really dreaded ever happened to
it
so our metrics collection set up with
we're shape we had unions employee for
handful servers but it's really awkward
to work with and in pretty much been
abandons we're sending the data directly
to our rails from Marilla
through sexy to graphite we had news
server system metrics to correlate with
it so in the fall of 2012 the algorithm
in our old managed hosting service and
were founding provider or making
preparations to move our entire
infrastructure to data center so at this
point all of our in the structure was
managed by shell and our plan was to
bring out the new data center
infrastructure entirely using chef and
nice and so we had an opportunity to
start fresh and started exploring our
options and quickly
offensive so why I sent you
Cynthia's Ruby which we know love at
first even though there's been two
components and server components are
written in Ruby tracks and plugins and
actually written in any language
there was already a fully fledged chef
recipe for sinzu factions who was
designed from the ground up with
configuration management and minds we
saw an opportunity to get involved with
the young project that we could
potentially contribute back soon
and in fact that since ooh community
plugins project was my first real open
source contributions and after nearly
two years living with and soon I still
feel strongly enough about it so when I
keep supporting it in any way I can
which is why
some other ravings bus and do you can
reuse your Nagios tracks so like in our
situation we're going to a tight
deadline and if we just have time to
implement or write our own since it
checks through being there just recycled
the negative stress all the metrics and
checks are reflected by one system you
don't have to have unit here Nagios here
and ARP in RPE etc since you have
documents and graphite integration and
it was reportedly easy to scale which
means it up later since you is an
incredibly flexible tool I've yet to
come up with the device or situation
that I couldn't somehow monitor with
sincere at sometimes referred to as a
monitoring router which I think it's a
really accurate description you can
handle any into it and have talked to
any other script sister are can't learn
if they want
so sincerely loves the cloud and deals
beautifully with ephemeral of machine
garments so we added an API called so
our people's best dev tools
so that's leading a node or silencing
mode as as simple as saying he being
sincere to lead this plan can also be
run and from say from Jenkins or
theoretically even from the client node
itself before being shut down into
leaders we can in vegan silence entire
environments at a time I think this
command which collects all the notes
from chef and then solace with been
losing the six to eight guys so thus
into is really well well written and
easy to parse even for someone like me
who's fairly new to Ruby
thus in Sioux community plugins
repository is quite big and is
constantly growing there's over 80
contributors over 600 plugins and you
can check it out and get up and see if
the services that you Roger are covered
but if not writing the checks is really
quite easy I don't consider myself a
programmer but I've been able to
contribute a handful of check so today a
people is posed we have to send to
environment suit production testing
production sometimes runs three up to
six instances of since who server
depending on the time year traffic etc
we have almost 300 send to clients right
now and we're pushing about 25,000
metrics per hour to graph I
we have one custom dashboard called hot
pot and one custom command line
interface which have shown to you which
was so all of us into your
infrastructure and is virtualized
it's already on VMware we're actually
working on vibrating with some of our
VMware infrastructure to open stacks and
our testing since you sped up its gonna
be on OpenStack soon but virtual
resources are fine you don't need
hardware since here we typically give a
thin to server box that they can have
RAM and four processors actually but if
that should just be two processors we
really only need four processors or if
you have a monolithic sense to install
so if you have since ooh and all about
eight components like running on one
p.m. that's really only timeouts
so overall our transition for nagios
just ensued was really incredibly smooth
but as we grew of course there were
problems here and there so initially we
deployed a single census server to
handle all production and it became
obvious it's time to scale when we saw
things like high load on the census
server and backed up cues and RabbitMQ
so one one thing that's great to monitor
but to get the visibility into the
health of your sim to set up is the
RabbitMQ ready queue size because if
that queue gets backed up and doesn't
drain and I'll get a little bit more
into the cop what role rabbit Hugh plays
in
so scaling is as simple as strapping or
anything of their descent to server
instance in our case we just have a chef
role person to server which brings up a
box earning just simply server maybe of
API dashboards and no a special
configuration is needed because all of
us insu components use the same
configuration bottle so you just start
out with another instance this is a
server and the checks would be
distributed in a round robin fashion to
all the six of servers
the only major pain music create
assistance you actually enjoy being
related to Graphite's yes no no please
interrupt okay are we talking multi data
centers all the census server need to
talk to the the additional senses server
instances we just need to talk to rabbit
and Q so you just need to know by four
seven money I'm sorry by six that went
by success to GCD and I mean there may
be some other forms but that should be
trivial
even here on graphite
so most of our our only real city
payments have been related to graphite
so we started seeing back to Hugh's
metric metric you specifically and
spotted grass in graphite and we've got
that throwing more sense of service the
problem really wasn't helping but it
turns out that our graphite cluster just
couldn't keep up with the large amount
of metrics through now serving it the
Assessor so the way we're connecting
graphite just into is we have CIN 2
pushing metrics into a rather special
rabbitmq cube and then graphite just
uses and QP to pull them down onto the
graphite server this is the AMQP
libraries and graphite are not
particularly performance but we've yet
to work out a better way I think I think
ideally the best thing would be to have
some sort of middleman between
like that could stand through harmony
life but in the end new year graphic
cluster two SSDs with part of the
solution the other part was to stop
collecting metrics every ten seconds was
been sooner that was just way too much
weed all our default collection interval
down to sixty seconds and lose some
stage new metrics to a staging craft by
cluster and then a person either bracket
a cluster
okay so now we quit not use in ten easy
steps so step one you can pay there's a
lot of talk in the ops community about
alert fatigue and moving through new
monitoring system is really a golden
opportunity to clear your slate clean up
your alerts and terms we really care
about and also because the differences
in the wage monitoring system implements
checks it usually makes sense to start
from scratch rather than try to port
existing check configuration over to a
new sister
it's also a great opportunity to stop
sending emails for people that don't
matter
maybe you want to see something on a
dashboard but don't want to get an email
every time it happens or maybe you just
want it to be the metric and not an
actual email one example of emails we
eliminated was for high load we stopped
sending emails or my memory usage and
just turned those into
step two is to plan we created a met
metrics and monitoring surveys
spreadsheets which is displayed here and
also shared I may give up if you're
interested but basically we're
collecting for each type of server hole
we reflecting what system checks you in
a run
what process checks to run but service
checks we run in what metrics system
metrics and service metrics do we want
to gather
the only thing that is not listed on
here that if I were doing this again I
would add would be the handlers when we
first deployed since ooh we only have it
that you know handler but now we have
different handlers for four different
things like we had a cage for duty for
life super critical alerts so our
requirements for checks if they must be
actual if you're sending the email for
it and nobody can do anything about I
finished the email if I wish would need
to be checked metrics obviously we went
nuts with those were deploying checking
them a little too frequently but we were
able to turn that down later so are the
global things the things that we checked
out every single server and cables post
our disk usage swap usage real internet
furnishings are swapping zombie
processes we don't leave all system the
metrics together are being stabbed disk
usage CPU memory and interface
performance and the handlers we use our
email campfire we have a special rooms
that I've been campfire it's only for
alerts and page the Rivoli only using
pager duty firm or one or two things
that you know really you know if this
needs to wait
the step four is defining these
specifics so now that you define what
you want to look at on every single
server let's look at each server role
and define additional states to be
checked and alerted on so some examples
of these different process attract are
there at least for a unicorn worker just
running them on this box that no more
than 20 system checks let's say maybe we
want to look at to see if something is
mounted specifically
certain server service checks they play
HTTP responses and service metrics to be
something like a a proxy fight and
announce rather hue-hue sizes
Step five set up a place to test I
recommend setting up a permanent testing
since we stack using your patient
management tool choice we use the census
chef cookbook which we actually had to
be customized in salalah room if I were
to do it over again I would just wrap
the since you shut up cookbook in a
wrapper cookbook honey desert chef users
okay how many year puppet users there's
there's also good puppet manifests for
sincere personally
so the testing server and structure will
be dual-purpose
one that'll let you test your
configuration management and then it
will be a good place to test things like
servitude server aside since you package
upgrades and women emergency comes out
miss Essex set up the workflow develop
and document workflow for implementing
testing deploying and signing off on
your tracks and you'll get really good
coverage if anyone whether it be
developers or offs can easily add text
and metrics definitive so an example
workflow here's how we do that people's
first so we had a new students each at
definition to the appropriate food book
in shop so we define service specific
checks within let's say we're setting up
in Janette stressful so those up in the
index the book will deploy the new track
to States to a staging environment using
chef we actually use Jenkins to deploy
our recipes
and we do glorify and give up that will
show know the code for this into check
definition we can put in sample graphs
or alerts we get a calling to sign off
on it and if we deployed
so here I'm showing you how easy it is
to define the since you check within a
chef recipe for the sandbox later were
actually not going to use chef but I
just wanted to give an example here of
how easy it is
okay step seven is execute your workflow
so we started with the low-hanging fruit
which was the plugins the already
existed in the community a repository
and we configured it an employee is
checked in the worksheet and signed off
on it and then started pulling from to
clients and to either select machines if
the check didn't exist in since the
community plans begin reuse an existing
items checked or ride around in Ruby or
ash
I would say in the beginning we reuse
290s tracks and everything else view for
the community and we probably ended up
writing maybe four five custom ones
step 8 is to set up some sort of bare
minimum third-party monitoring for the
city servers you know this
self-explanatory you just need something
to do this
down which is not happened as yet but it
still gets there we use pin Optus
agent-based monitor just to check that
the sense of server machine is alive and
check that the disarm hole
some other idea to be kind you're
testing since you set up monitor your
production since Ursa and since you can
collect metrics about itself see don't
need a third party for veterans
collection step 9 roll out your
infrastructure so you older you're gonna
have already well tested server
infrastructure from your testing
deployments and this should go pretty
smoothly because you've got a lot of
practice rolling out administer and that
testing setup the first you'll stand up
those into new server stack and then
we'll up to clients the rest of Europe
Russian czar burgers burritos and sets
in to the alerts rollin and politely
need to thresholds occurrences it better
work once you can do checks turning an
actual production traffic
okay a little above us into architecture
so since X is RabbitMQ for all
communications to the client and server
the rabbit and Q and Redis are all
running on the system server VM sandbox
and as well as the dashboard which is
not matured over here the API and the
server and reticence used to persist
data for use by the API
since you package contains all this
dependency
you bus installer which means that did
that's everything it needs into ops
ensued which is really often because you
don't have to worry about whether your
sister Ruby is going to complete your
bit or work with it and if you don't
want to the sauces to Ruby then you
don't have to ok so you guys are ready
any questions
I don't I mean we have let's say 300
clients about five to ten checks of your
on on every single server and then you
know maybe five on top of that for each
additional server role the real load
instance ooh from us who's four metrics
collections and I mean obviously we were
having an outage or periods of high
traffic we're getting more more sips of
traffic but no I don't have
earn numbers of how many checks on
Friday
it's create community
okay so our goals of what the sandbox
are to get everyone familiar with
distance to configuration we're going to
install a handler deploy a check trigger
an alert on this check and in general
have to be something to take from an
icon so if you mess anything up you can
just spin your call and finger up and
worst case scenario you can destroy it
and have it again but that takes like 20
minutes provision so the sand boxes are
two virtual boxes Cinci server and has
been two clients they were built using
vagrant in shock they're earning
asymptotics or and to end up to since I
created this tutorial since you 12-0
that I just rolled 0:12 out to
production and people suppose they're
sorry
so open up your terminal and open up an
SSH session in zubur with your server
and your client at the end and then go
ahead and CEO two routes just for
convenience everything
and let's take a look at the sincere
configuration
okay so everything's dude big JSON is
the configuration file I was mentioning
earlier that's used by all the sensors
so this configuration file is thank
where rather than Q is running so on
this setup we're just running rabbitmq
rhetta's and all units on fly em if you
were running this in production you
might want to have a rabbit of cube
separate machining or even a rabbit in
between cluster because it's pretty
critical to juice health and well-being
anyone here have you three turning round
and cute cluster okay I'm going to talk
to you so telling us consumers for
Ennis's we're rather curious where the
API is and where the dashboard is and if
you look at this configuration file on
your client machine is exactly the same
okay so empty since you compte
is where the client configuration with
sticking with bats and then smile is
just telling consents you at the name of
this client what its address is and what
its descriptions are so let me talk a
little bit about what subscriptions are
so there are two ways to implement
checks in sindhu you can have a
standalone check which is when in the
check is defined on the client machine
itself the server has no prior knowledge
of that check it's just defined the
Louisville ball system and it tells
since a client what to do and when to do
it there's also the pub step model which
is where the server tells the clients
what to run and winter run we do and
people are supposed we're doing
basically a combination of the two but
most of our checks are sampler so today
we're going to be using a subscription
based checks so we're going to compute X
on the server and the server will tell
the client to execute them and publish
result
and the other part
that's it then zoo are pretty
self-explanatory a folder for extensions
handlers mutaters and plugins and then
SSL configuration so let's look at
plugins and these are the ones I've
already installed they're all Raviv they
all keep in Cincy community plug-in
repository you can take those if you
want handlers
we have no handlers so that's what the
first thing we're going to do is it's a
finger
okay so let's trigger our first learn on
your since appliance well first let's
open up the dashboard both because that
a second go ahead and stop us into
clients on the since appliance p.m.
and that will take 120 second before it
raises a keepalive alarms on the server
that interval is suitable but the
default is a hundred second
so it's your favorite provision
correctly this should be the IP and the
username and password for your sense of
dashboard I was having some major
problems earlier and my dashboard is
actually running at 192.168.1 10
that you can see I have two clients
since appliances server
Oh
we shouldn't be keep alive the water
here but we can check back
is the what is the handler a handler is
something that takes action on an event
using a pipe tcp/udp and VP or it can be
a set of other anchors examples are some
emails that pager do need and metrics to
graph I think I call whatever whatever
you could write to the default handler
it is debugging which means it just
writes the event to the log and displays
it on the dashboard so a basic very
basic handler is simple if you send an
email and then an advanced gambler would
be handler that actually attempts to
remediate alert so they run a custom
script that spins up additional ec2
instances with the high
I say we're gonna configure an email
handler it was
and informative email for an event so
I've already installed the mailer
plug-in for you that's the net system
zoom handlers so now that you configure
it so on your sensor server machine if
you'll open up as you consume company
handlers maelard up JSON
so this is the Jason all over you can
tell the emails should be from and where
it is you go to this is a really simple
handler strips that you can't inherently
change a good sense to based on
attributes three things but it slides
right so negative that should be fairly
easy
we're going to actually figure to
handler
so if you'll copy this assistant to
company handlers default of JSON to
email that JSON and then we're going to
edit that Bob normally you would be kids
and an EPG some of the files see if your
chef or puppet or whatever your
configuration management would be doing
this for you so if it seems a little
painful I just didn't want to use chef
do all this because anyone who will take
this check was the only option for
setting up
so now we're going to edit this even all
that JSON
so we're just telling you the type of
handler is a pipe and the command to be
run as
Zoomers male arm
see
okay so part of installing since you
plug in is our plugins and handlers
booth is making sure the gym
dependencies are met this handler in
particular depends on the male gym so
you could check to see if that gym that
is installed and to better do be using
this command but I've already installed
it for you so because of working has
roots you'll wanna fix permissions
and then we started services
so we're gonna service start since the
server restart and then we're going to
look at the server log and Bret for mail
hopefully I didn't
okay so I messed up the JSON
okay so that's what we wanted is that 50
Paul apply changes we've added a handler
okay so subjects since a client runs the
tracks that are defying their schedules
either mobley which is a standalone
you know there or 50 server which is the
subscription and it checks into results
as an event to a handler and this
applies to anything service tracks for
veterans and checked execution is
scheduled by the server or scheduled and
today we're going to do a
subscription-based check on the server
that will run on our client
so let's configure a check
we're going to use check drop stop army
to make sure that these one
cornbread is right so to determine the
first thing I would do in spelling a
check that's turning with the check
command is going to be so on your send
to clients we're going to test out this
command so we'll we'll call the plug-in
uses the sanzu vetted movie and then
I'll show you check cross
so it actually doesn't pronounce usage
yeah the hell is it very expensive
the basically we're telling it - P is
good foot patterns rec for and then the
capital W one is that we want at least
warn us if there's not at least one part
read process running those tests back
commands and we get a warning because
they're very processes actually we're
going to say that that man
and we're going to install the tracks so
we're going back to the census server
let's open up f ze zijn zoon concept de
checks for current process
okay let's walk through what each part
of this check configuration means the
corporate process is remaining with a
check the handlers are the email that we
set up as we wanted to make this
effective handlers your duty here first
gotta fail to define a check navigating
an emergency
the notification is just you know
something descriptive we're out of
breath command is the command we just
tested the subscribers are all basically
added the client to a subscription group
called all which is all in the clients
picked up JSON we wanted to run every 60
seconds and we wanted to learn after one
occurrence and then with butter it's
true because it's cornbread is always
better than butter and I just wanted to
show that you can put any arbitrary key
value pair and this is super big that
could be used by this than to plugins
and handlers
yo you can actually aim it
JSON
yes yes you can
okay so we need to find the chat and now
we're gonna be started since the server
actually the Ministry London
and now let's look at the log while
reading hairs
and what you're seeing by our economics
a traffic you been inspired from reddit
metrics that were set up automatically
when the QuickBooks I used so they're
kind of fluttering from the law
I don't think that check got booted
yes
the particular
check the dashboard and dr. Clark
okay so we've gotten our keepalive
larimar since you client showed up and I
forgot to tell you a story starts with a
client on the Cintiq line via so if you
want to do that to see your corporate
alerts we can go back to do clients and
start
so now as the dip I will start out and
so
now we're seeing the check requests come
into the server the server saying run
this particular commands and
results
so we didn't have to be easy to fly
inside that walls and server side so now
let's see if we got a female
we did not venom actually I think I may
have set up an email address but in
theory you should have gotten an email
although showing that they're new
processes
and this is what the email looks like
it's it's really simple
it just says what hosts that lurking in
on the timestamp the address of the
client question the check name the
command is run and how many times is it
apart
so let's talk a little bit about this
into a guy as sincere and service API
runs on hgp four five six seven
understand to server you can try curling
events and you'll get a list of all in
partner games you can pipe it to the
book Mike on JSON tool to make it look a
little prettier
so now we have another view into our
current sanzu events it's good to not
have to depend completely on one
dashboard and to have our interfaces to
what's going on
so the census services are consuming the
eye which we just query 50 server which
is what actually issues and processes
issues with checked processes the check
results and basically struggles tab
between this new client server and in
the sensi dashboard hiding check and
everything is okay it's all in the
debased you can just do sensor service
law start/stop status restart all the
logs are far log sent to you and you can
curl the API visit info endpoints which
will give you useful information and the
even use percussive check wanted
so it's saying that revenue is connected
we have at least one consumer of people
like you without least one consumer the
results view and Redis is connected and
I can I'm sorry just like a fan
all
my client is dead
wait
and if you if a machine comes online it
starts to decline for the first time it
registers itself server if that's the
quickly stopped sending supplies you're
getting implants so even if you machines
down
okay so some cool sanzu tricks you can
send events directly to sensu using
netcat Sims who listens on 3030 since
you client tennis so you can do this on
any of your client machines you can just
echo out a JSON event directly to 3030
and it should show up on your dashboard
I tried to do this live before it to
work so good I'll try it anyway
dude listening must rise
fail I haven't installed that cat
sorry
but it works the problem
attribute alerts and attributes are
really awesome for preventing alert
floods so one use case words we have
let's say we have 20 web app servers and
we don't want 20 alerts it HTTP goes
down on all of them
maybe you only want one alert with 50%
of them are down another person to
personal tips for me install the rabbit
and human and web interface and boots
markets let me give you a quick view of
that
whenever I think something might be
wrong with since it's usually the first
place I go
this is an older version of grabbing a
few of the newer dashboard is is a
little nicer but but this is this is the
big thing we care about this very cute
if you've got 10,000 messages sitting
there ready queue and it's not draining
that something is wrong with your since
it set up it's also just kind of fun to
like poke around and see what put my
cues and connections since it creates
another thing I recommend is locking
your plugins Egyptian fantasy versions
so if you write a plug-in and let's say
it depends on the Redis gym in your
configuration manager recipes there like
in our chef recipes I specify the exact
version of that Redis jintan salt
because I've got fit before with just
the latest gym being dissolved and not
working so there's some more tips it has
to have alternative ways to access your
dashboard information I showed you the
API that's like our developer you can
take that and run with it we've
integrated our fan line tools that's
into API and we've also created our an
ops dashboard that crazed into graphite
and are out for data all top haven't
pulled it up for you but if anyone's
interested afterwards like
another tip is to put engine X in front
of stem suit dashboard
since you got four runs on a beard port
and acts to log in every time so if
you're running in behind you know if
you're inside your data center and
you're not worried about security you're
not worried about whatever logging in we
just passed through all medication using
in fact have you makes them too highly
available or redundancy it's really easy
to just bring up horse into servers but
making Redis Ravin a queue of highway
bill to be more challenging and there's
not really haven't found any
documentation or recommend the best
practices within the seven
so that paperless we're still running
one solitary menace and one solitary
rabbit into you but we're actually a
minister now because it doesn't take as
long you know in an emergency we take as
long to bring up a new instance of that
because raisin shop
so where do you go for help there's
docks that since you have top org which
are quite good the absolute best place
to get help I found is to channel on
freenode I try to hang out there and
contribute back as much as I can and
there's a sense you user expand list
questions
I was thinking to pull just really
simple like paint rects on a couple like
begin employment and devices but I
haven't gotten as far as doing me like
SMB checks but people have done it we're
just not doing it yet
I'm not personally to you but it is it
is possible I wasn't aware it until
recently but apparently there are some
dependency
ha
yes yes there is we are using that more
more frequently we're like we have a
plugin that pulls JSON out of graphite
value and might and alerts on that based
on
if it is I will be very soon asking you
my colleague to do lower quests and
publish it to continue plugins but I
believe there's already a check
Jason brought by King Solomon plugin but
if you don't see it out there if I don't
see it we would gladly share ours
we use the front end called Rafi every
row to give us first
yeah graffiti is open-sourcing
Shawn quarter the person who wrote in
Zubrowka chef
we say running multiple sensitive
servers before without secrecy
surrounding our next question yeah I'm
not sure we would need quite that many
into servers if we were only using it
for monitoring
yeah it's basically just growling the
metric to grab
yes you can use mutaters and a mutator
to take anything and mutate it anyway
all right well if you guys have any
other questions you can reach me at
Bethany pebbles viscom I'm sky Bob on
Twitter and I grew up with